well let's begin with Harvard Law
Professor Alan dershowitz who wrote the
book get Trump and Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett tribal of the
century author well they got him uh uh
it seems Professor you know uh we don't
have all the charges we have four of the
seven I'd like to get the specificity
within the indictment as I'm sure you
would
this should be the strongest indictment
the strongest case ever brought against
either a former president or a potential
presidential candidate since Richard
Nixon if this doesn't meet the Richard
Nixon test you remember Richard Nixon
you know bribe paid destroyed evidence
if this doesn't meet that test if this
is not the strongest case ever then
obviously this will be seen by the
public Democrats and Republicans alike
as partisan Justice designed to prevent
the people from deciding who the next
president should be and giving that
decision over to judges jurors and
prosecutors that's a violation of the
rule of law violation of the
Constitution so I wait with the baited
breath to see whether the indictment in
this case meets that very very high
standard of the strongest case in
American history if you're going after a
man who's running against the incumbent
president it better be the strongest
possible case so far I haven't seen
evidence of that
uh New York Times Greg reporting Trump
is charged with a total of seven counts
including willfully retaining National
Defense secrets and violation of the
Espionage Act making false statements at
an obstruction of justice conspiracy uh
according to people familiar with the
matter so
um you know on the surface of this
um how do you not how do you not look at
immediately begin the the rightful
comparison of Hillary Clinton and and of
course the top secret classified
information on her servers that we're
told that even they believed that
foreign adversaries got a hold of how do
you compare it to that how do you
compare it to documents top secret
classified documents in four locations
for Joe Biden if it's an obstruction
charge how do you say the deletion of 33
000 emails and the destruction of
devices with hammers is not some type of
obstruction charge and how do you how do
you now compare and contrast the
treatment of two Democrats and one
Republican
two systems of Justice Sean one for
Donald Trump and one for everybody else
Merrick Garland the Attorney General is
criminalizing a civil dispute over
documents that's governed exclusively by
a civil statute the presidential records
act that act means anything created
during a presidency whether it's
classified or not
can be maintained by a former president
period but instead of seeking an
injunction let's say or production of
Records in a civil court let a judge
hash it out Garland chose to bastardize
the law by raiding Trump's home and then
seeking an indictment today and it
didn't matter that Trump was following
the very same standard as to abolished
by the Department of Justice itself a
decade ago in the Bill Clinton case who
kept classified documents that was a
standard endorsed by a federal court in
Washington
the president can keep what he wants but
Garland didn't like that and he doesn't
care about the law so he abandoned his
own precedent because it's Donald Trump
this is selective prosecution it is
unequal Justice yeah it's okay for
Hillary to mishandle classified
documents uh no charges for Joe Biden to
do the same but if Donald Trump does it
it's a high crime
you know what about the obvious
comparisons Professor dershowitz
um because I don't think he would have
supported charges for Hillary or Joe
Biden either would you
no I don't think we should be
criminalizing these decisions to take
either accidentally or deliberately
material home I believe that every
single president in my lifetime
everything
has taken some classified material with
him and remember a president doesn't
have to cooperate with people he
believes are trying to get him
you have to show that he crossed the
line into criminal obstruction that
defendants are entitled to be tough and
to play hardball and to say look I'm not
cooperating I'm pleading the fifth I'm
pleading the fourth I'm pleading the
sixth I'm getting tough lawyers we're
gonna fight this you don't have to be uh
Joe Biden and roll over and cooperate
with the government it is no crime to be
tough and to resist you have to show
that there was a corrupt motive and if
president Trump believes he had
Declassified the material before he left
the White House then he had no
obligation to turn them over to the
archives so I agree with Greg this is a
civil case that should have been
resolved civilly and this better pass a
very high standard if we're going to
accept the administration going after
people who are running against them you
know how serious that is when you have
one Administration criminalizing the
actions of the person who threatens to
do the administration to make sure that
Merrick Garland doesn't hold on to his
job and the people at the top of the
justice department don't hold harm onto
their job you have to have the highest
standards that's why I call it the Nixon
standard remember they went after Nixon
not because the Democrats wanted him out
of office but because his own party the
Republicans believed that he had
obstructive Justice let's see if this
gets bipartisan support
you know Greg in light of the Durham
report that came out and all the real
malfeasance that was described in that
report you know everything from the
double standard in terms of how they
treated Hillary Clinton versus uh what
they did with Donald Trump how this case
never ever should have been open
operation Crossfire hurricane you have
the entire media mob I'm sure like we
have going on as we speak uh you have
every left-winger in the country they're
celebrating they're happy Etc
but all of that all of those lies told
on all of those networks broadcast and
cable and of course you know the
Washington Post New York Times they got
it all wrong never should have been open
no apologies no Corrections no new
oversight uh no no changes put in place
to prevent something like that from
happening again and that leads into the
pre-bunking of the hunter Biden laptop
Story by the FBI uh which I would argue
had an impact on the 2020 election
um certainly you know telling big tech
companies that oh you might be hearing
you know might be a victim of
misinformation and it may be about
Hunter when they knew pretty damn well
that that laptop was going to be leaked
by Rudy Giuliani who was then Donald
Trump's attorney and they knew how to
copy of that laptop that they had
verified themselves so yet they're
telling them if you read something about
Hunter don't trust it and that's how
that story got censored isn't it you
would think after all of this that has
come out after so much time maybe they
would think that we shouldn't be acting
this way but it seems like there's more
arrogance than ever before
yeah the Durham report was a damning
indictment of corruption at the FBI and
to some extent the doj but you know
corruption in the swamp runs deep and
make no mistake this is all Merrick
Garland's doing as I said the other day
the most partisan attorney general in
history now together with a bias special
counsel Jack Smith who has a history of
abusing the law for political purposes
together these unelected people are
corruptly interfering in a presidential
election they're trying to eliminate Joe
Biden's opponent while simultaneously
protecting Biden and his son that's the
only way that Garland hangs on to power
he has derailed the case against his
boss and his family's influence peddling
schemes ignoring volumes of
incriminating evidence that they sold
out America to Nations adversaries for
millions of dollars in cash how else
Sean do you explain a five-year
investigation with no criminal charges
and how do you explain how Joe Biden got
so rich on a public servant's salary
all right Craig Jarrett and Alan
dershowitz thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else